Now I want to ask you one quiz question.
What if we wanted to return or to print all values of the filled-in formula
rather than just the first one?
For some of these formulas there are multiple possibilities of digits to fill in
that would all work equally well.
If we wanted to see them all, if we wanted to have them all printed out, what should we do?
Should we change the function fill-in to return a list rather than generate results?
Should we change the single word "return" to "print" in the function solve?
Should we change the function valid to do something else to validate
each of these possible formulas?
Or do we need to add a new function to do something that we haven't done before?